so you're saying that the interrogation
process works when there's an other
person interrogating them yes so let's
take something we're slightly different
scenario maybe I'm kind of making a
different way around it in that let's
take a movie like the revenant
and let's take few glasses character
before the bear attack
so he's alone in the forest how are you
interrogating Hugh glass to be you know
stumbling upon the bear or encountering
him how are you getting him ready for
that okay first I'm just getting back to
what you said the beginning
interrogating involves someone else so
the interrogation process is usually
between someone who's not in the scene
and the person who is in the scene so
whether there's one person in the scene
or 12 people makes no difference matter
okay that each actor needs that other
person and usually someone who's not in
the scene got it so but getting to and
how do you interrogate someone to play a
scene like Hugh glass is scene where
he's going through the forest the woods
and then he's attacked by a bear one
thing you've got to be very clear about
no the interrogation is pretty simple
yet profound for a moment like that but
first of all you can remember in any
scene the character that you're
interrogating does not know what's
coming up in the scene this is a problem
between the character and actor the
actor knows Leonardo DiCaprio he knows
exactly what's gonna happen there's
gonna be a bear and he's gonna have to
fight it off got it the character
doesn't know that and then this is the
power of interrogation I've got to get
his mind back into the characters mind
and away from the actors mind the what
the actor knows this is a little detour
what the actor knows what's coming up in
the scene
the lines I have to say what I have to
do that's all there but it's in the
background okay it's not driving
everything because it can't drive
everything because it is not known by
the character I will trust it it'll
always be there I will trust it the
actors will always say the lines they'll
follow the stage and they'll do the
mechanics no problem so it's not about
the mechanics I'm worried about what I'm
worried about is the
mindset of the characters or
interrogating Hugh glass before the bear
I have to know and so does Hugh glass
have to know what the hell are you doing
what are you doing where are you going
into and what are you expecting now in
the interrogation I could say okay I
could be talking to him where you're
going okay you got to go you're gonna
get that you're gonna let's let's say
he's looking for food I'm just making
this up because I don't recall what he
was - he's just moving but he knows what
Hugh glass knows what he's doing even if
we look at the scene we're not sure what
he knows what he's doing and I've
through the interrogation I am going to
plant in his mind or inject or question
and we're going to establish through me
between me and Hugh glass what he's
doing what he's looking for right now
through that interrogation I could also
I can start you insinuate potential
danger you know you're all alone you're
all alone out here yet
I mean what if something happens now he
knows as the actor I'm setting the
character up for what the environment
and what's going on and actually setting
the character up for the scene the actor
knows that because a bear coming Hugh
glass is just saying yeah I know it's
doing it but I'm fine
you got your way I'm a guy I got my
rifle I'm fine I said you sure could you
handle something to something and
whatever elk cub does know I'm now I'm I
want to get him into our mindset a
specific mindset of my choice the
mindset could be I'm fine I'm in no
danger at all that's one mindset another
mindset is I know I'm out here alone and
I shouldn't be and this is a stupidest
thing you should ever do that's a
different mindset where do I want to
take him what mindset do I want to put
him in and I can set up that mindset and
then the beauty of interrogation is you
work with the character you're
interrogating the character and you set
up a mindset a belief system and
attitude just before the scene a lot of
actors will talk about that moment
before the scene where what are they
thinking about just before the scene
when the interrogation I can create that
anything I want and then
what I do which I love because then I
send them into the scene naive an actor
will go into the scene with a plan this
is disastrous because the actor when's
the last time you went into a 3-minute
moment your life with a plan knowing
what you're gonna say and what you're
gonna do and how you were gonna react we
don't do that that's not authentic
that's acting my job is to send the
character into a scene naive having no
idea what's gonna come on because I want
the genuine authentic reactions to the
events that happen to the other lines
that said to the attack of the bear to
the realization that he's been stupid
whatever I want it to happen
authentically I don't want him to plan
it the actor will try to plan it the
character can't plan it so if I get him
in the the mind of the character
believing something totally different
than what's going to happen then he will
react to every single moment
authentically and it'll probably
surprise him and it probably surprised
me the guarantees I can make to every
directors if you work this way and you
sent a character into a scene naive
without a plan knowing that yes the
actor will say the right lines and do
the blocking and do all that but without
and planned for the emotional journey
he's going to go through how he's gonna
react to anything no plan I'm guaranteed
number one the actor will not know what
he's gonna do at all certainly the
character doesn't know because the
character is just going through it actor
1 you the director will not know what
he's going to do but everything he does
will be authentic and that's what we're
going for and then you get to choose in
post-production as we talked about
before which moment you want and then
when you do take 2 you set him up
slightly differently a different mindset
may be a more cautious mindset this time
for you glass
maybe a mindset of deriding himself
stupid what are you doing on ok then him
trying to convince himself he's going to
be ok and he shouldn't be out there he
will react differently then now if you
do it three or four takes like that and
he reacts differently and you've shot
them all you realized the range of
material you've got that you and it's
all authentic you can build the most
beautiful scene possible
you